[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue sur rt france très
heureuse de vous retrouver pour ce
nouveau numéro de la grande interview
notre invité aujourd'hui nathalie yang
membre du parti d'opposition ivoirien
liberté et démocratie pour la république
elle est conseillère exécutive de
mamadou koulibaly qui est candidat à la
présidentielle ivoirienne nathalie
jambes c'est aussi la dame de sotchi un
surnom qu'elle a hérité après ce
discours très remarqué contre la
françafrique lors du sommet russie
afrique à sotchi en octobre dernier
nathalie yang bonjour merci d'avoir
accepté notre invitation sur rt france
bonjour merci
alors comme je le disais dans mon
introduction ce fameux discours de
sotchi c'est un discours qui a été
extrêmement sévère envers la france
c'était presque un discours de rupture
c'était totalement un discours de
rupture une rupture à laquelle aspire
des millions d'africains et qui dont il
est temps qu'elle sait qu'elle se
concrétise effectivement et est ce que
finalement quelque part le fait d'être à
sotchi en russie sur un territoire qui
est peut-être un peu moins lourd et moi
dont l'histoire commune est peut-être
moins de violentes ça a joué dans ce
disque ont salué un impact dans ce
discours au peut-être je ne sais pas moi
c'est un discours que je tiens depuis
plusieurs années c'est pas c'est pas un
discours nouveau mais il est vrai que le
contexte peut être dans lequel il se
tenait l'environnement des chefs d'état
des hommes d'affaires le fait que ce
soit en russie ça certainement ajouter à
l'impact de ce discours et ça a
certainement secouer un peu plus les
tenants de la françafrique qui ne l'ont
pas du tout apprécié au contraire de
millions d'autres personnes
est ce que vous aviez conscience au
moment de prononcer ce discours qu'il
allait avoir une telle déflagration
aussi bien sur le continent africain que
dans la diaspora
non pas du tout parce que comme je
voulais dit ça fait des années que je
répète le même discours je pense que
c'est peut-être vraiment le contexte
dans lequel il s'est tenue qui a qui
explique ces déflagrations
le fait que les médias français s'était
attelé à minimiser la portée du sommet
russie afrique etc et que ce discours là
se soit tenu là bas ça a surpris tout le
monde moi j'étais vraiment la première
surprise de de l'ampleur que cela a pris
je suis j'ai sorti de sotchi je suis
rentré en côte d'ivoire c'est un voyage
de 27 heures j'étais pas connecté je
suis arrivé à abidjan j'ai trouvé que le
discours avait fait le tour du monde
quoi
et est ce que pour vous pourrez rappelez
peut-être dans les grandes lignes pour
nous téléspectateurs qui n'ont pas vu ce
discours est ce que vous avez dit la
soutient en octobre dernier
auger simplement j'ai simplement rappelé
le fait que contrairement à d'autres
puissances coloniales la france ne veut
pas partir ne veut pas renégocier les
termes de la collaboration avec ses
anciennes colonies qu'elle maintient
toujours une servitude coloniale sur les
pays de l'afrique francophone à travers
nos francs cfa dont nous ne voulons plus
et qui empêche l'industrialisation de
des zones concernées que nous ne voulons
plus de l'armée d'occupation française
qui étale ses bases et ses tentacules
dans nos pays sans jamais empêcher que
ces mêmes pays soient déstabilisés par
des terroristes par des djihadistes ou
même par par d'autres forces et que nous
ne voulons plus de la tutelle française
au niveau de l'onu
nous sommes en afrique tout à fait
capable de parler pour nous même de
porter nos résolutions de saisir nous
mêmes le conseil de sécurité sans que ce
soit la france qui s'arroge le droit
d'être notre tuteur alors nathalie yang
quelques semaines après votre
intervention le 2 décembre 2019
très précisément que vous êtes expulsés
de côte d'ivoire alors pour je cite
activités incompatibles avec l'intérêt
national
comment vous réagissez à ce moment là
est ce que vous êtes sous le choc
ou vous attendiez à cette expulsion
je m'attendais à une ' réplique violente
du régime j'avais bien constater quand
je dis
au tour que sotchi a vraiment porté un
coup dur à l'édifice françafricain et
donc je m'attendais à quelque chose de
la part de ce régime et de ses donneurs
d'ordre je ne savais pas la forme que ça
allait prendre
je pensais aussi peut-être que je serai
emprisonné qu'il y aurait enfin il y
aurait des mesures de rétorsion certes
je m'y attendais je ne savais pas quelle
forme elle prendrait ça ça a néanmoins
été effectivement un choc en ce sens que
pas que j'ai été foncièrement surprise
de mon expulsion mais de la manière dont
elle s'est faite de l'irrégularité dont
elle s'est fait alors que bon peut-être
que j'aurais dû m'y attendre ce régime
est et est coutumier de la violence et
de l'illégalité de l'iri grille et
irrégularités vous avez évoqué un motif
qu'on m'a communiqué comme ça
verbalement au moment où j'étais à
l'aéroport alors justement c'est quoi
ces activités qui s'ouvre est contraire
aux intérêts et à l'intérêt national
c'est quoi ces activités en question
vous expliquer on m'a rien expliqué du
tout je constate que les activités dont
il serait peut-être question ici puisque
je voulais le dire tout à l'heure on m'a
jamais notifié quelque chose par écrit
je n'ai jamais reçu un document qu'elle
compte lors des onze heures
d'interrogatoire que j'ai passé à la
préfecture de police d'abidjan il n'a
jamais été question d'activité
quelconque à part mes critiques acerbes
comme ils disaient contre le régime donc
j'en conclus que ce sont mes critiques
contre le régime et contre la
françafrique qui sont considérées comme
des activités à une compatible avec
l'intérêt national se pose la question
si il est vraiment dans l'intérêt
national d'être une colonie française
ce qui est intéressant c'est que
finalement ce discours vous le tenez
vous reteniez sur en côte d'ivoire sur
le territoire ivoirien
et finalement c'est au moment où vous le
tenez à
l'extérieur que vous êtes sanctionné
voyez c'est très amusant je trouve ça
très très loufoque un peu je pense que
c'est l'exposition médiatique qui a fait
mal à monsieur ouattara et par extension
peut être monsieur macro vous avez on
peut critiquer monsieur ouattara comme
on veut sur le territoire national s'en
fichent pas mal mais dès lors que ça
passe une critique passe sur un média
étranger ou au niveau de la communauté
internationale ça le touche beaucoup
plus que toutes les critiques qui
peuvent être faites sur le sol ivoirien
ou pas mais alors nathalie gang lors de
ce discours de sotchi vous avez aussi
déclaré je vous cite la france considère
toujours le continent africain comme sa
propriété
nous voulons sortir du franc cfa nous
voulons le démantèlement des bases
militaires françaises qui sous le
couvert d'accords de défense bidons ne
servent qu'à permettre le pillage de nos
ressources
l'entraînement de terroristes et le
maintien de dictateurs à la tête de nos
états alors ma question est la suivante
est ce que le problème selon vous c'est
la france ont plutôt on va dire certains
chefs d'état africains qui sont qui
seraient adeptes du statu quo d'ailleurs
vous avez qualifié d les présidents
africains de laqué et de momies donc
vous avez quand même des termes très
durs à leur encontre a donc je pense que
j'ai des termes qui décrivent
parfaitement leur comportement je le
problème est que combiné on a un
problème avec nos chefs d'état qui
acceptent voilà de servir de faire
valoir et de passer les plats à une
puissance coloniale qui refusent de
s'adapter à l'air du temps
il y a nous avons deux adversaires en
face de nous nous avons la france qui ma
foi on peut lui reprocher tout ce qu'on
veut mais elle elle défend ce qu'elle
considère comme ses intérêts je trouve
que ceux qui sont encore plus à
critiquer sont ceux qui à la tête de nos
états lui permettent d'arriver à ses
fins en et en utilisant les intérêts des
peuples d'afrique alors nathalie de ce
discours à sotchi vous a fait connaître
du grand public et à l'international il
vous a projeté sous les feux de
l'actualité
finalement on vous connaît assez peu
quel a été votre parcours
on sait que votre mère et suisses votre
père est camerounais vous vivez enfin
vous viviez jusqu'à votre expulsion en
côte d'ivoire vous êtes quand même
engagé politiquement
quel a été votre parcours
écoutez moi je suis né en suisse de 2
par an donc suisse et camerounais j'ai
passé les premières années de ma vie en
suisse ensuite mes parents nous ont
amenés au cameroun où mon frère et moi
avons vécu avec eux pendant neuf ans et
puis je suis retourné en europe cette
fois ci en allemagne pour faire mes
études commencé ma carrière
professionnelle
je suis revenu en afrique en 99
en fait j'ai décidé de quitter l'europe
pour donner naissance à mon fils en
afrique j'ai survenu à ce moment là et
j'ai commencé une carrière
professionnelle
d'abord au cameroun puis au nigeria puis
en côte d'ivoire puis au ghana puis de
nouveau en côte d'ivoire voilà je suis
journaliste je suis étudié journalisme
j'ai travaillé comme journaliste née
pendant que j'étais en allemagne
et lorsque je suis revenue en côte
d'ivoire je travaillais dans la coupe
banque en afrique pardon j'ai travaillé
dans la communication et puis plus tard
dans les ressources humaines où j'ai
fait toute une carrière depuis on va
dire 2000 2004 et vous me considérez
toujours comme journaliste aujourd'hui
au vu de votre engagement politique est
ce que c'est compatible
je me considère pas comme journaliste
puisque comme je lui dis ça fait très
longtemps que je ne le travail tue comme
journaliste mais c'est ce que j'ai
appris c'est mon métier c'est ma
profession même si j'ai fait carrière
dans les ressources humaines et dans la
communication
alors est-ce que depuis votre expulsion
de la côte d'ivoire vous êtes retourné
là-bas ou si c'est pas le qu'est ce que
vous espérez un jour à y retourner
je ne pense pas que je puisse retourner
en côte d'ivoire tant que monsieur
ouattara est au pouvoir
comme je voulais dit ce gouvernement a
refusé de donner des papiers qui
permettrait de faire un recours contre
une décision totalement has
z'y va donc je ne peux pas y retourner
tant que monsieur ouattara est au
pouvoir mais tel que les choses se
présentent cela ne devrait pas durer
très longtemps et je serai capable de
rentrer en côte d'ivoire c'est prochaine
on a lu alors sur certains sites web
on a vu que vous étiez fichiers en
france que vous étiez interdites de
territoire en france est-ce que vous
pouvez clarifier ces rumeurs finalement
qui circule sur les réseaux sociaux et
sur internet
bon c'est un peu difficile de clarifier
certaines rumeurs parce que je n'ai pas
les moyens de vérifier s'ils sont rumeur
ou si elles sont avérées ce que je peux
dire c'est que je ne suis pas interdite
de séjour en france
je suis je possède un passeport suisse
donc qui me permet de circuler partout
en europe depuis mon expulsion j'ai eu à
retourner en france
j'ai pas j'ai pas eu de problème
particulier au contraire les gens du
quai d'orsay ont plutôt cherché à me
rencontrer par tous les moyens possibles
et imaginables
en ce qui concerne le fait que je sois
affiché s en france je n'ai pas
d'information un fichier est ce n'est
pas fort son appel pas quelqu'un pour
lui dire à l'eau bonjour je vous informe
que vous êtes fichés est ce fichier s
d'après ce que je sais c'est qu'on est
considéré comme quelqu'un qui est
potentiellement un trouble à l'ordre
public en france peut-être que je suis
fichée s7 au gouvernement français qu'il
faut demander
merci nathalie en ont fait une petite
pause et on se retrouve tout de suite
après dans la grande interview
[Musique]
de retour dans la grande interview avec
natal yang militante suisse aux
camerounaises qui nous parlait de sa
relation avec la france alors nathalie
ans vous nous disiez que vous n'aviez
pas a priori de problème mais en tout
cas à venir sur le territoire français
contrairement aux rumeurs qui sur
qu'est-ce qui circule sur les réseaux
sociaux est ce que vous pensez que c'est
peut-être une façon de vous
décrédibilisez ou alors en tout cas de
vous quelque part de criminaliser de
vous montrer comme quelqu'un de
dangereux
oh certainement en fait moi je vous ai
dit quand je suis venu en france en
décembre juste deux semaines après mon
expulsion il y avait j'ai participé à
une conférence donnée par le professeur
mamadou koulibaly pour la diaspora à
paris et j'ai été accroché par des
dirigeants du quai d'orsay qui m'ont dit
les yeux dans les yeux qu'il me trouvait
dangereuse ils m'ont dit textuellement
vous est brillante et c'est pour ça que
vous êtes dangereuse donc je crois
qu'effectivement il ya la nécessité
d'une part de mme estampillé comme un
élément dangereux
et puis d'autre part d'essayer de
décrédibiliser le message que je porte
est-ce que vous suivez l'actualité
française et quel regard vous portez sur
la question du racisme qui est
omniprésente dans l'actualité française
actuellement oui bon je suis un peu ça
de loin je ne suis pas une adepte de la
télévision je dois avouer pourtant je
suis journaliste et les à la balle mais
je vois bien les thématiques les
thématiques relatifs au racisme après
les après les faits qui se sont déroulés
aux états unis et tout ça beaucoup de
manifestation contre les violences
policières avec par exemple le comité
justice pour adama il y a aussi eu cette
polémique autour de 7
de cette illustration de valeurs
actuelles d'une députée française qui
était représentée en esclaves
il ya aussi une polémique concernant
cette liste de médecins noir qui a
circulé sur les réseaux sociaux
c'est vrai qu'on sent en fait on sent
une colère chez la jeunesse afro
descendantes
est ce que vous vous la comprenez être
comment vous l'analysez vous oui bon je
la comprends je la comprends d'autant
plus que je suis moi même une afro
descendantes qui maintenant par la force
des choses et relocalisée en europe pour
l'instant momentanément et que non
seulement on se retrouve confronté à ce
genre de stats isation ici en europe
mais en même temps on n'a aucune chance
de se développer d'avoir une vie
meilleure en afrique parce que c'est
toujours le même système de l'état
français qui qui empêchent les
populations et d'être prospère et
heureux en afrique et d'avoir des
carrières comme il faut ou la justice
qu'il faut quand elles sont en france
c'est irritant bien sûr et finalement
est ce que vous pensez que c'est pour ça
que ce discours que vous avez fait à ce
qui a eu un tel un tel écho je pense que
le discours de sotchi retranscrit
vraiment les aspirations de millions
d'africains des jeunes africains des
moins jeunes
beaucoup de gens sont venus me voir
après même des personnes plus âgées qui
me dit madame on sait pas où vous
trouver le courage mais vous avez dit ce
qu'on n'ose pas dire j'ai eu des hommes
à des ministres en exercice de
différents pays africains qui sont venus
me féliciter qui me dit vraiment on vous
soutient vous avez raison etc s'étaient
tous fait c'est tellement étouffant
cette mainmise jusqu'au boutiste de la
france c'est à dire la france n'est pas
le seul pays qui a eu des colonies dans
le monde mais c'est le seul qui refuse
d'avancer qu'ils refusent de s'adapter à
l'air du temps d'accepter un partenariat
gagnant gagnant
avec ses anciennes colonies et je
constate aussi que c'est le seul pays
qui colonisateur dont aucune des
colonies n'a jamais été développé quoi c
'est une colonisation appauvrissante qui
est maintenue au forceps sur les
populations d'afrique et que ce soit les
africains d'afrique où les la diaspora
tout le monde en ressent les effets
négatifs et il ya un immense ras-le-bol
qui est là qui avance comme un rouleau
compresseur
ce serait naturellement beaucoup plus
beaucoup plus efficace si l'état
français le gouvernement français prenez
en compte cette réalité s'asseyait pour
discuter avec nous accepter de ceux de
nous débarrasser de ces instruments de
colonisation qui nous ont mis dessus
mais s'ils ne veulent pas le faire de
façon consensuelle bon ce sera fait de
façon unilatérale du côté africain
alors justement comment faire en fait
pour établir cette relation gagnant
gagnant
qu'est ce qu'il faudrait faire
concrètement le premier pas le seul
parent d'ailleurs c'est pour nous
africains de porter à la tête de nos
états des gens qui sont animés par la
recherche de l'intérêt de leur
population
si vous avez à la tête de l'état une
personne dont la préoccupation
principale n'est pas de plaire à paris
ou de courir à paris chercher des
instructions mais de mettre en oeuvre
des réformes qui vont permettre aux
populations du pays qu'il ou qu'elle
dirige d'accéder à la prospérité
d'accéder au bien-être d'accéder au
travail d'accéder au confort alors les
choses se mettront en place
naturellement les trois choses dont je
parle
la monnaie qui empêche
l'industrialisation c'est une lettre
écrite par un président qui elle forme
le reste de la côte de l'union monétaire
que lui ne se retrouvent plus dans le
cfa est donc entame la sortie du franc
cfa
après avoir diligenté un audit des
comptes d'opération et
entamée entamé le processus de retrait
c'est une signature sait rien d'eux
puisque sa seule chose qui manque c'est
une personne qui a du courage et la
volonté politique de le faire alors
nathalie on va parler des élections
présidentielles ivoiriennes qui devrait
normalement se tenir à la fin du mois
d'octobre une campagne la compagne
actuelle se déroule quand même dans un
climat qui est extrêmement tendue depuis
le retour d'alassane ouattara dont la
course puisque l'actuel président
ivoirien est revenu sur sa promesse il a
décidé de briguer un troisième mandat et
depuis cette annonce le pays est secoué
par des manifestations
quelle est votre lecture vous avez de ce
revirement d'alassane ouattara ce
revirement ne m'étonne pas je suis juste
je fais partie des rares personnes qui
ont de façon constante affirmé
qu'alassane ouattara sera candidat à
l'élection présidentielle gelée affirmé
même après qu'il ait annoncé sa pseudo
intention de ne pas se présenter je
monsieur ouattara a échoué sur son bilan
il revient aujourd'hui dix ans après
avoir accédé au pouvoir avoir avoir eu
les mains totalement libres parce que
contrairement à son prédécesseur il n'a
pas eu à faire des gouvernements d'union
il n'a pas eu à gérer une rébellion
pendant la moitié de son mandat il était
totalement libre
il avait toute la communauté
internationale à ses pieds il a eu il a
bénéficié d'une opposition qui n'a pas
comme lui eut recours à des rébellions
ou à des putschs pour le chasser et
néanmoins dix ans après après être
arrivé au pouvoir il se retrouve devant
nous en nous disant ont écouté j'ai pas
encore fini et puis vous savez dans mon
parti si c'est pas moi
ces personnes je suis à la tête d'un
parti qui est au gouvernement depuis
vingt ans puisque le rdr a été au
pouvoir avec gbagbo
à l'époque dix ans le rdr seul avec ses
alliés du rhdp et dans tout ce dont tout
cet immense formation politique soit
disant il n'y a pas une seule personne
qui est capable de remplacer le candidat
qui est décédé
avant d'ailleurs que les candidatures ne
soit définitive ne soit annoncée par là
par le conseil constitutionnel
je trouve ça navrant mais je ne suis pas
étonné monsieur ouattara a peur de
l'après ouattara il regarde ce qui se
passe ailleurs sur le continent et tous
ceux qui ont mal géré leur pays ont une
peur bleue de ce qu'il adviendra
lorsqu'ils ne seront plus aux manettes
pour contrôler la machine ce qui
explique qu'ils prennent en compte le
décès de personnes la répression les
pertes de vies humaines
juste pour continuer d'être d'être à la
tête de l'état de côte-d'ivoire et de
pouvoir continuer à le piller à le
maintenir dans la pauvreté alors on a
tellement on a vu
des membres de l'opposition finalement
regretter le silence de paris i la vie
de ce qui se passe en côte d'ivoire est
ce que ce n'est pas paradoxal et
contradictoire de dénoncer l'ingérence
de la france dans les années dans la
politique africaine et en même temps de
condamner le silence de la france sur ce
qui se passe en côte d'ivoire
je trouve ça tout à fait tout à fait
paradoxal je souris quand j'entends ça
parce que je trouve ça navrant
qu'on soit que l'on condamne le silence
de la france soit que l'on se réjouisse
de certains agissements de la france
parce que in fine et ce n'est pas la
france qui décide qui dirige la côte
d'ivoire
si on continue de regarder du côté de
paris et de l'elysée a pour essayer de
déchiffrer s'ils sont pour ou contre
nous bon ben on n'a qu'à laisser
monsieur ouattara au pouvoir parce que
il n'ya pas meilleur serviteur de la
france que monsieur ouattara
on se demande si les opposants qui se
réjouissent ou qui s'énerve par rapport
à la réaction ou non de paris veulent
simplement remplacer monsieur ouattara
au pouvoir pour faire la même chose ou
bien s'ils veulent réellement changer un
système et je suis très fier de
constater que en cage dans mon parti
politique leader son candidat a établi
de façon très claire que peu lui importe
est là la réaction de paris à l'élection
présidentielle nous ne souhaitons pas
que paris s'immisce dans l'élection
présidentielle niveau arrive alors ce
qui est intéressant c'est de voir que
alors d'un côté paris il reste très
silencieux sur la situation en côte
d'ivoire alors que la france et la
communauté internationale de manière
générale a très rapidement réagi au coup
d'état qui a eu lieu au mali et capoue
ces ipk a renoncé au pouvoir c'est deux
poids deux mesures comment vous lisez ça
comment vous analyser ça oui bon c'est
vous savez au mali c'est la sela
l'opération barkan qui est en jeu la
france souhaite par dessous tout
maintenir l'opération barkan maintenir
l'armée française au mali et dans la
sous région
pourquoi faire on ne sait pas trop bien
parce que quand on regarde le bilan de
l'opération barkan c'est plutôt un échec
total
l'émission qui ne s'était assignée n'ont
pas été remplies alors on se précipite
on condamne un coup d'état
au mali ce qu'ils ont décrit comme un
coup d'état au mali mais si l'on regarde
bien c'est une volonté populaire qui
s'est établie et d'ailleurs si les cas a
trouvé bon de démissionner ensuite mais
quand on se préoccupe de la soi disant
démocratie au mali mais quand il s'agit
de la côte d'ivoire ce pilier du pré
carré on est prêt à fermer les yeux et à
regarder ailleurs pour plus tard venir
donner des leçons de morale de
démocratie nous jouer des pompiers c'est
l'attitude de la france dans toute sa
laideur et dans tout dans toute son
habitude
voilà nathalie aumont arrive vers la fin
de cette de cet entretien
une dernière question est ce que vous
pensez que les africains sont prêts à
rompre avec la france et à se tourner
vers de nouveaux partenaires tout à fait
je suis certaine que des africains sont
prêts à ça c'est d'ailleurs ce qui
explique la portée du message que j'ai
et que j'ai tenu un sotchi c'est ce qui
explique d'ailleurs aussi le fait que
nos coups de boutoir contre cet édifice
françafricain oblige paris à venir
raconter des inepties par rapport à la
fin du cfa et cetera les africains sont
prêts à se tourner vers d'autres
partenaires mais ses autres partenaires
ne sont pas forcément hors d'afrique ça
peut être des partenaires africains
ce que nous voulons c'est avoir des
relations gagnant-gagnant avec tout le
monde
on n'exclut même pas d'avoir des
relations gagnant-gagnant avec avec la
france si celle ci accepte nos
conditions à savoir que quand on fait un
contrat ça ne doit pas être 99% pour
vous et 1% pour nous mais ça doit être
du fifty fifty ou même du 60 40 70 30
pour nous parce que c'est nous qui avons
le matériel les ressources naturelles
etc les africains sont prêts ce sont les
ce sont les îles et l'état les
représentants de l'état français et puis
leurs valets à la tête de nos pays qui
essaye de repousser l'échéance mais elle
arrive inexorablement merci à nathalie
yang son congrès a donc c'est la france
qui a plus à perdre que les pays
africains merci nathalie ample d'avoir
répondu à toutes nos questions sur rt
france c'est la fin de ces grandes
interviews merci de l'avoir suivi vous
pouvez retrouver cet entretien sur nos
réseaux sociaux et sur notre site
internet
rt france point tv quant à moi je vous
retrouve très vite sur rt france
[Musique]